Robert Downey Jr.'s career may have reached
astronomical heights when he was cast as Tony
Stark, a.k.a. Iron Man, in the very first
film of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
but he already had a long career before
that, with a ton of ups and downs.
So you might be surprised to find out
that he doesn't consider his best film
to be "Iron Man," or any of his
Marvel blockbuster appearances!
Downey started out doing roles in '80s comedies
like "Weird Science," and then proved his dramatic
acting chops in "Less than Zero." In the '90s,
Downey's film credits were a bit hit or miss.
On the one hand, he received an Oscar nomination
for his portrayal of Charlie Chaplin in the
biopic "Chaplin," and his starring role in the
1995 historical drama "Restoration" was well
received by critics, plus he had a recurring
role on the hit TV series "Ally McBeal."
On the other hand, movies like the
sappy rom-com "Heart and Souls" and the
underwhelming thriller "In Dreams" weren't
a big help in moving his career forward.
And after a serious drug addiction derailed
his career in the late '90s and early 2000's,
Downey Jr. struggled to find work, as few people
in Hollywood were willing to take a risk on him.
That may be one reason why, during
a 2020 appearance on the "Joe Rogan
Experience" podcast, Downey Jr.
said that his best film is also
the one that had the most importance
to his career: "Kiss Kiss Bang Bang."
Released in 2005, "Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang" is an action-packed dark comedy
produced by Downey's friend Joel Silver.
Downey told Rogan that it was, quote,
"in some ways the best film I've ever done."
"It came out, and it bombed, but Jon Favreau
saw it, and he said, 'This guy could do an
action movie.' And that wound up being my
calling card into the Marvel Universe."
Jon Favreau, of course, directed and
co-starred in "Iron Man" in 2008,
and he gave Downey Jr. his next big launch into
stardom. And though "Kiss Kiss Bang Bang" only
made $15.7 million worldwide at the box office,
it was a big hit with critics, with a Certified
Fresh score of 86% on Rotten Tomatoes to
go along with an audience score of 87%.
"Kiss Kiss Bang Bang" was also written and
directed by Shane Black, who Downey later
brought in to write and direct "Iron Man 3"
after Favreau bowed out of the franchise.
Like Downey, Black was also in a career
slump before "Kiss Kiss Bang Bang."
The writer/director had previously found
great success writing and producing movies
like "Lethal Weapon" and "The Last Boy
Scout," but after "The Long Kiss Goodnight"
bombed at the box office in 1996, he
struggled to find work in Hollywood.
"Kiss Kiss Bang Bang" was Black's attempt
to start over by branching out from straight
action movies. The fact that he himself
had trouble finding people to take a chance
on him may have influenced his decision
to give Downey a second chance as well.
Thankfully for all of us, Black took the risk and
hired Downey to play one of the main characters.
Though "Kiss Kiss Bang Bang" didn't do very well
at the box office, it did become a cult classic.
The quality of the film helped revive both
Black and Downey's careers, and set the
wheels in motion for Marvel to also take a risk
on casting Downey in the first "Iron Man" film.
It's hard to believe now, after Downey Jr.'s
breakout performance as Tony Stark set the
stage for the Marvel Cinematic Universe to
become the biggest film franchise in history,
but when he was first cast in "Iron
Man" in 2006, there were many who were
skeptical Downey Jr. could be trusted with
the responsibility. His work on "Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang" was good enough to convince Marvel to
take the chance, though, and the rest is history.
No wonder Downey thinks it's his best film!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.